اذا المشاهدين الكرام اليوم الثاني لهذه
الهدنه واليوم الثاني عشر المعارك
المتواصله بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع تبقى الخرطوم هي عنوان المعارك حتى
هذه اللحظه مع التركيز الكبير على المناطق
الجنوبيه من الخرطوم او مدينه الخرطوم
طبعا نشير بشكل سريع كما نعلم في اكثر من
مناسبه ان الخرطوم تتكون من ثلاثه اقسام
رئيسيه او ثلاث مدن رئيسيه هي الخرطوم
بحري المنطقه الشرقيه من الخرطوم الكبرى
وام درمان المنطقه الغربيه والشماليه
الغربيه ومدينه الخرطوم التي تشكل المنطقه
الجنوبيه والتي تحتوي بشكل اساسي على
المراكز الحساسه والمراكز القياديه في هذه
النقطه عند ملتقى اني لين الازرق والابيض
اللذان يشكلان النيل الصاعد نحو مصر عند
النقطه الصغيره هذه التي نشاهدها الصوره
الاقرب
هذه هي الصوره الاقرب عندما نتحدث عن هذا
المربع الذي يشكل نقطه التقاء النيل
الازرق مع مناطق مدينه الخرطوم مع النيل
الابيض في هذه المنطقه فنحن نتحدث عن
مساحات ضيقه يعني نتحدث تقريبا عن مسافه
لا تتجاوز حوالي ثلاث اربع كيلومترات في
هذا العمق ومسافه لا تتجاوز خمسه الى سبعه
كيلومترات في هذا الاتجاه من الشرق الى
الغرب صوره اقرب لهذه المنطقه نتحدث عن
الاشتباكات التي تدور بشكل اساسي
والاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع قوات الدعم السريع
تتمركز في نقطتين اساسيتين في هذه المنطقه
محيط المطار عندما نتحدث عن محيط المطار
نحن نتحدث عن الحي او الاحياء الشماليه
الشرقيه من مطار الخرطوم الدوله الذي
نشاهده على الشاشه هذا هو المطار المطار
يقع في وسط مدينه الخرطوم كما نشاهد ومحاط
بعدد من الاحياء السكنيه والاحياء
السياديه الصحه التعبير المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه تتمركز قوات الدعم السريع في هذه
النقطه وايضا تتمركز في المقابل قوات
الجيش في مقر القوات المسلحه او في مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه على الجهه
الشماليه الغربيه من مطار الخرطوم الدولي
وايضا هناك هنا حي المطار القوات الدعم
السريع تقول بان قوات الجيش ضربت مراكز
قوات الدعم السريع في المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه ويقول الجيش بان القوات الدعم
السريع ايضا استهدفت مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه بهجمات اليوم ليكون هذا
الاتهامات هذه هي الاتهامات المتبادله بين
الطرفين في خلق الهدنه في يومها الثاني
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع تقول بان القوات
الجيش ضربت القوات الدعم السريعه
المتمركزه في القصر الجمهوري طبعا هذا
المربع كما ذكرنا يضم القصر الجمهوري مقر
القياده عام القوات المسلحه وايضا بعض
الوزارات وزاره الداخليه وزاره الخارجيه
وعدد من الم المهمه قوات الدعم السريع
اليوم تقول بان قوات الجيش ضربت مواقع
القوات الدعم السريع في القصر الجمهوري
لتؤكد قوات الدعم السريع بان قوات الجيشيه
التي اخترقت الهدنه في يومها الثاني كما
نشاهد هذا هو المربع الاساسي ولكن
العمليات العسكريه لم تتوقف عند هذه
النقطه اذا ما انتقلنا الى صوره ابعد او
صوره اكبر للعاصمه الخرطوم اليوم تقول
قوات الدعم السريع بانها رصدت تحركات
لقوات الجيش قادمه من منطقه الشماليه
الجيش يعزز تحركاته ودعمه لقواته
المتمركزه في الخرطوم عبر المزيد من
الامدادات القادمه من مناطق الشماليه طبعا
المناطق الشماليه تشهد او فيها معسكرات
للجيش المنتشره في المناطق الشماليه
الشماليه الخرطوم وبالتالي تعزز القوات
السودانيه
تواجدها في هذه المنطقه مع بعض العمليات
العسكريه او الاشتباكات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من ام درمان عند ملتقى النيلين
في هذه المنطقه العاصمه الخرطوم في
المقابل تقول قوات الجيش بانها رصدت
تحركات لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه من
المناطق الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه عندما
نتحدث عن مناطق الغربيه وبشكل اساسي نتحدث
عن ولايات دارفور الخمس التي تشكل المنطقه
الجنوبيه الغربيه من السودان وايضا ولايات
كردفان التي تشكل المناطق الجنوبيه
الغربيه بطبيعه الحال من مناطق السودان
لتكون هذه المناطق ايضا مناطق توتر بعد
اعلانات الجيش بان القوات الدعم السريع
تحاول تكثيف قواتها بتعزيز امداداتها
العسكريه من المناطق الجنوبيه قوات الجيش
تقول بانها تتصدى لهذه القوات القادمه
مناطق الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه وتقول
بانها تسعى لضرب هذه القوات قبل ان تصل
الى العاصمه الخرطوم مسرح العمليات
العسكريه في اليوم الثاني عشر التي تحول
فيه قوات الدعم الس السيطره على مربع
الامن الذي ذكرناه قبل قليل في مقابلات
الجيش لانها تقاتل او تسعى وراء بعض
الجيوب لقوات الدعم السريعه المنتشره بقي
ان نشير ايضا ان عمليات الاجلاء ما زالت
مستمره في البلاد حيث ما زالت عمليات
الاجلاء عبر ميناء بورتو السودان في هذه
النقطه متواصله بشكل اساسي وايضا بشكل
اساسي عمليات الاجلاء او عمليات
النزوح واللجوء باتجاه اثيوبيا وباتجاه
جنوب السودان وباتجاه تشاد ايضا مع اعداد
كبيره نازحين حتى الان وصلت تقريبا الى
عشره الاف نازح خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه ونحن نعلم ايضا ان السودان بشكل
عام فيها اكثر من ثلاث فاصله سبعه مليون
نازح بسبب الاضطرابات الكثيره في السودان
اذا نحن نتحدث بشكل اساسي في عمليات
الاجلاء والنزوح عن اتجاهات نحو اثيوبيا
بشكل اساسي والمعسكرات مخيمات اللاجئين
المقامه على الحدود وايضا باتجاه جنوب
السودان لمن يتمكن ذلك وباتجاه ايضا
الاراضي المصريه مع رصد حركه نزوح باتجاه
تشاد على الحدود مع تشاد بطبيعه الحال رغم
ان المسافه كبيره جدا بين الخرطوم والحدود
التشاديه السودانيه نتحدث حوالي عام 1200
كيلو متر النقطه الاساسيه لعمليات الاجلاء
هي ميناء بورت سودان ومطار برج سودان حيث
تتحرك هذه الافواج برا من الخرطوم باتجاه
بورتو السودان ومن بورتو سودان اما عبر
المطار مطار بورتو السودان الى جده بدرجه
اساسيه جده السعوديه او عبر الباخرات
البحريه التي تتحرك في البحر الاحمر هذا
هو المشهد الميداني بشكل اساسي حتى هذه
اللحظه ولكن هذا المشهد له ارتدادات
انسانيه كبيره ربما نتحدث عنها لاحقا
الوضع الميداني حتى هذه اللحظه مشتعل في
العاصمه الخرطوم واختراقات للهدنه
واتهامات متبادله بين طرفي الق